dozens of Venezuelans waiting for food
many haven't eaten since the previous
day when they were brought to this
refugee camp in Bogota it's the first of
its kind the people here are angry they
say the authorities haven't kept their
promises the tents are cold and wet
their few belongings were confiscated
for hygienic reasons Carlos Adrian is
here to take care of his grandmother who
fled Venezuela a few months ago he says
they were better off when they were
living on the street they offered as
many things we've never received a
decent bed we had our own mattresses
that even on the floor were less cold
than what we have here where we
virtually sleep on the ground it was so
cold last night my bones were aching
imagine how cold it was
they took our blankets almost all of our
stuff and food now we're making a fire
over there but we have nothing to cook
because they took it all in a Mozilla
Camino Lockheed are the media isn't
allowed inside the camp after some
refugees come out to talk to us the
guards won't let them back in
there are small children inside who've
had nothing to eat they want to feed
them with a single banana and water we
have no showers were not animals there
are no human rights activists or any
other agencies here to tackle the
problems began gallo many Colombians
have helped us and we appreciate the
help we got on the street some came here
last night it's so unfair they brought
food for us but weren't allowed inside
and we weren't allowed to go out and get
the food for our kids they were inside
crying because they're so hungry a few
days later videos shot by neighbors
overlooking the camp show some refugees
stealing food shortly after the police
arrive riots begin
[Music]
the authorities respond to the unrest
saying they will deport 15 Venezuelans
we're introducing two key measures the
first is biometric identification that
from the start now refugees will be
identified not only by name but also
biometric second we will boost security
in the area in addition to the beefed up
security measures we've already taken
but locals say those steps don't go far
enough
they fear for their security and their
businesses we opposed the authority's
decisions they were arbitrary they've
moved the Venezuelan community to a camp
with very bad conditions 12 bathrooms
for 480 people what guarantees can they
give to people who have to leave their
belongings and their children at home
when they have to go to work locals are
worried that there are hungry people who
will go out to ask for food and money
yesterday there was an incident at the
bakery they came in and asked for bread
when they didn't get it they just
grabbed it though most Venezuelans are
grateful for the reception they've
received in Colombia they desperately
want to settle down and start a new life
outside the refugee camp